you know I wanted to give some examples
of fake wives now fake wives are all
throughout Hollywood and we have the
more obvious ones like Jada
obviously um but you know every now and
then I'll see a clip and and there's
little telltale signs that you can tell
that is a fake wife let's pull it up
along and so I didn't commit commit in
fact until he proposed to me there was
no real commitment as such even if we
were technically allowed to maybe see
other people yeah we would just keep
coming back to each other uh second
unfair to me or to the other person or
to the relationship itself I think um
I'm not someone who's been frivolous in
relationships I take my relationships
very seriously and when I'm in one I'd
like to give it 100% And I don't think
I'm ready for that technically allowed
to maybe see other people we would just
keep coming back to each other um
so I'm
yeah so what does this mean what does
this translate to he was the safe guy
she knew that she could basically do
whatever she wanted and he wouldn't
leave she still she wanted to sleep
around with the guys that she was
actually attracted to and get the
resources from him that's a fake wife
because when you think of femininity
what what is femininity is that is that
a feminine thing to do to want to date
all of these
people and then have your the guy that
you marry on the back burner so some of
the comments say deep depa I don't even
know how to say this DEA
padukon DEA PUK I'm sorry guys the most
fakest personality that exists in
Bollywood and I actually I don't even
know where this chick is from I don't
know Bollywood um someone said maybe
different phases of her life back then
that's what she thought giving 100% to a
relationship at after having three to
four relationships that none of them
worked she was in the phase where she
wanted a casual relationship I guess we
all humans do that it's not just
recorded and I think it's gone on for a
while I think there's a reason that dads
would protect their daughters from
certain guys and say stay away from my
daughter and obedient daughters right
that that were more Fe like because
feminine women are obedient so obedient
daughters would listen to their father
and the disobedient daugh daughters
would end up in a single motherhood or a
shotgun wedding um and that's what the
red pill talks about they really just
look at patterns of behavior with women
and the thing is a lot of women don't
have genuine desire for their husbands
their husband was the safe fallback guy
and a lot of times women treat him as
such even if that is true why is this
woman publicly saying that why why are
you embarrassing your guy and the
problem is
one none of the men check the women so
they don't even tell the women how out
of line that is and two we've gone
through a society where that's like cute
funny and it's not it's not cute it's
not funny and that's embarrassing to
your husband i' also talk about how the
last generation of real wives
really are are women between the ages of
roughly 70 to 90 and I'm not saying
there aren't real wives after that
they're totally were but let's just say
women between the ages of 70 to 90 let's
say 70% were real wives then we go down
to the women between the ages of 40 to
60 now 40% are real wives then we go to
the women under the age of 40 maybe 20%
are real wives now what's a real wife a
real wife is a woman that submits to
serves and obeys her husband number one
a real wife does not get divorced she
doesn't believe in it and she will make
the relationship work at all costs even
at the expense of
herself what is important to a real wife
is the family she does not spend money
on Botox on the latest fashion trends
the only thing she cares about is
looking good for her husband she's not
posting on social media she's not
seeking validation and attention from
other men that is a real
wife now I I have no idea how this woman
acts and her relationships but what I do
see from the older generation is the
ability to be honest and be real and I
saw this hilarious Grandma um basically
being put on like a vice type panel with
some weirdos let's pull that he's gay
ask how he identifies how do you
identify actually I identify as uh oh
here we go it's that long plethora of oh
my God wait for it I will let me get a
chair somebody please reach out to this
women woman we need her on the show
please tell me where I can find her that
is hilarious that is so
funny and that that's the thing they
didn't grow up with this nonsense so
it's semi all this craziness started I
remember when I was in college like that
was like the that was when the Bruce
Jenner stuff came out that was when all
of the left woke [__] started to
come out when I was in college when I
was in high school I don't remember much
of it so I can't even imagine being like
70 80 90 years old and seeing how much
the culture has switched where everyone
used to have
families and get married and maybe CU
you know the 70s still like the the
crazy 60s and 70s still existed but you
know it was still normal to you know
maybe they would do crazy stuff when
they were young but they would still get
married and have have a family where in
my generation most women probably will
not have a a family most women if they
do have children it will not be under
the context of marriage so people that
are 70 80 90 years old have really seen
the degradation of the culture so the
comment section says she's seen a lot of
BS in her day and she ain't having none
of this BS I love it Judge Judy's sister
is a real Savage yeah oh my gosh someone
needs to make Judge Judy a YouTube
channel
and the reason I think my generation is
so confused is because they have lied to
us we have been fed egalitarian nonsense
our entire lives now what is
egalitarianism I'll give you an example
it's all about balance what does that
mean my opinion is just as important as
my husband's no no no no your opinion is
not as important as your husband I
believe in patriarchy I believe in
submitting to men's author Authority
relationships do not work
otherwise there are people that still
stay together but the relationship is
out of order and you can typically see
that in the children the woman has to
respect the man she has to otherwise it
does not work that the man has to come
before the children and before yourself
it is always the man first and that is
what we have been taught wrong is
egalitarianism you should have equal say
your opinion matters and then we wonder
why we're so confused and our generation
can't make it work um and so there's a
street interview of a woman being asked
who comes first her child her husband or
her father let's pull it up who comes
first your son your husband or your dad
let me tell you something my husband
he's number one he's number one who's
number two my child and then your dad
but then my dad yes why your dad last
though my dad will be be first if I
wasn't married okay so even if you're
married why him
last because my mama got
him okay my mama got him I don't have to
hold him down my mom's silent tell you
[__] but he's your dad though he's my
dad but my mom's 100 and she's 15 years
younger than my daddy tell I should
never have to take care of my daddy it's
on her type [__] it's on her and she's a
Scorpio she holds it the [__] down my
mom l her virginity to my daddy they've
been together for 50 years so they doing
what they supposed to she's right yes
yes yes relationships and family
structures do not work unless the
husband is put first he has to come
before the children because what happens
if she doesn't put the husband first the
entire family breaks down and typically
you can see it in the children I'll give
you an example before the Jada and will
debacle happened before the famous slap
before Jada talked about Tupac before
the entanglement before all of that
people loved will and J that look of
love that I was looking at right there
between you and your husband I love it I
need to rub a little bit that hey that's
for 20 years will get I know I know who
I know who's here after 20 years she
knows your S I know the TCH know the
scent I know the energy everything I
told her we were just talking about that
I said that look of love that I saw when
you all walked on this carpet my
goodness you know that cuz we've
survived you know yeah we've survived
you know and it's the that that's the
thing that is difficult that people
don't understand about love you think
it's all flowers and everything but love
gets created by making it together
people loved will and Jade I remember
having this conversation with my mom a
couple years ago and I said something is
wrong in that house household something
is off because their kids are weird and
you will see this in households with
weak fathers you will absolutely see
they could be together but if you have a
weak father that is why you see Bill
Gates's daughter seems to be going the
direction of being a [__] I think I
don't know but based on what I've seen
the same thing with the Obama's kids you
know they're coming out they're fat
she they're smoking drugs or whatever
where you know Trump is
divorced but his kids turned out a hell
of a lot better when you have a dad that
actually doesn't take [__] from the
women and actually leads his household
you cannot tell me that Trump is not a
leader and it is not going to be what he
says goes in the household and you see
even though he's three times divorced
his kids turned out a hell of a lot
better than a married family where the
husband tolerates disrespect if you
tolerate disrespect from your wife you
are teaching your kids that and now you
have a situation where Will's kid is
crying over Tupac and publicly
disrespecting him so she's actually
absolutely right where the husband has
to come first and what happens if the
relationship breaks down the kid's more
likely to be homeless the kids more
likely to drop out of school the kid is
more likely to commit crimes if the dad
doesn't come first then the whole family
breaks down and this is actually why I
question why women and children get on
the boats first I know and no this is
this is gonna this is very out of left
field but I question if that's really
correct because when you think about it
if the men aren't saved then Society
crumbles and they'll always argue that
like one man can impregnate a whole
island or whatever
but you still need men to protect
Society from other people otherwise
they'll just kill the guy and grab the
women so when you think about it if the
the family unit is going to break
anyways because okay think think about
it like this think about it like this
the ship's going down the man sacrifices
his life for the women and the children
this is just me thinking out loud guys
well then what happens well then the new
guy comes in and kills the kid I mean
that that's what would happen in the
animal kingdom right the new guy comes
in the kid's gone or the kid so messed
up like the daughter becomes a [__]
because she doesn't have a dad or the
daughter
becomes crazy or whatever now we have
more crazy
people
so I question if that's even right and
then you get rid of all the men the men
make all of the Innovations in society
they protect
Society what why is the magical womb you
know men have gotten so far they might
even be able to create woms that's how
talented men are so I actually question
the notion if the men are supposed to
lay down their lives for their family
because you know or like they they
should go down where the because like
it's almost out of order when you think
about it I don't know I'm just that
that's more of a a thought I've had
recently is that really the correct way
is that way in order why do the women
and the children get on the boat but not
the men it seems a bit out of order
you'd almost you'd almost think it would
be better to have like I don't know the
top five families get on you know I
don't know I'm just thinking here okay
so the first comments are from women
they say husband over your child oh no
oh baby Nar what is n a UR no I don't
know why why can't we spell as chicks
all right no man is coming before my
child gorgeous gem says and this is why
we have so many failed relationships the
husband has to come first the Bible says
husband comes first good for her yo it's
Gabby um my child is number one my dad
is number two my husband is number three
that is the only right answer and I bet
if we clicked on their profiles they
would be fat single women because guys I
don't make the rules people want to say
that pearls so mean I'm just telling you
the truth and relationships only work if
the woman submits to the man's Authority